how do headlines like this actually
affect you like I I saw this and it made
me really think about where all of you
were going in 2024 and I just wanted to
put this out there okay so in the macro
our economy is doing different things
right what's going to happen 2024 the
smartest Financial minds are debating
are we on fire uh in a good way in a bad
way these headlines are going to
continue to come through a headline you
see all the time is Gen Z will not be as
successful as their parents meanwhile I
know unlimited kids in gen ZZ right now
who already make more money in a month
than their parents do in a year because
they're using modern technology whether
it's Tik Tok or flipping or Shopify or
many other things that are brewing in
our society the key to this video is
what are you going to do in 24 the
reality is is that you're actually in
control and many people win big in bad
economies and lose big in great
economies so stop looking at these
generalizations and focus on what you're
going to do this year